men domination is a conservative writer
and publisher of the Federalists website
good morning good to be with you so what
does this do for the president in the
political context of what happened last
week this rolling back of environmental
regulation you know it's it's an
interesting time for the president right
now he's facing a lot of different
challenges from a lot of different
directions and he's trying to find
frankly a good win that he can give his
supporters after the debacle of this
health care law in the last week he
wants to find something he can deliver
on very quickly in order to change the
narrative in law second question what
does it do to the environment climate
change in the planet you know I think
this is going to be an interesting
question going forward when it comes to
these different Accords the real
question that I think a lot of people
have about climate policy is whether
we're going to be able to deliver on the
kind of changes that we need to achieve
and whether that can be done during that
through government regulation at all a
lot of the skepticism on the right side
of the aisle is whether that can
actually be achieved through Accords
like the Paris agreement instead I think
they're looking to things like
technology technological advancement and
other changes in order to increase the
kind of health and and clarity that we
have within our environment and then the
long experience so now their calls for
Devon Nunez to recuse himself for this
investigation do you where do you see
that going been and do you think it's
necessary to have legitimacy in this
investigation
I think you do need to have a legitimate
investigation except there right now we
do have an investigation when it comes
to the Russia side of things from the
FBI and James Comey and I think that
when it comes to these types of calls
they're much more a representation of
the partisan interests of Democrats in
Washington as we've seen in the past the
powers of the minorities in Congress in
order to influence administrations
really do come from the investigative
side that's what's going on here
chairman Nunez is actually someone who
has a lot of trust within the Republican
coalition as being someone who is not a
camera hog or someone who chases
headlines that's one of the reasons why
you got this job in the first place
there does appear to be a lack of
transparency there is a lack of
transparency at this part at this point
on his part but I think one of the
reasons for that is that he has a
history of cultivating a lot of
intelligence sources within the
community he was a clear sort of source
of the information that related to the
effect of intelligence when it came to
CENTCOM and Isis a few years ago one of
the real questions going forward is what
really matters here is it the
question about Donald Trump's tweet I
don't think it is at all I think there
is an open question if what Chairman
Nunez is claiming is correct if there
really was intelligence information that
was distributed throughout the agencies
and he now claims in an interview
yesterday to the Obama White House
itself that is something that deserves
further inquiry and it's one of the
reasons we need more transparency in
this process he hasn't he hasn't
discovered anything and he hasn't shared
it with anybody really you don't think
so
he showed up at the White House yes and
was received some information from a
source that he's not even disclosed
either other Republican or Democrat in
the committee it's relevant wouldn't he
share that with other members of the
committee I think one of the interests
that wiretap Trump town of course
nothing nothing to do with though with
what's going on here in the sense that
he went to the White House to go into a
secure facility ask if in order to view
information that is only available
networks through the executive branch
that is not available at the skiff that
they have on Capitol Hill he never heard
of that okay well members of the
Intelligence Committee go all the time
up to Capitol Hill and give them
briefings in secure facility absolutely
absolutely but I think that in this case
he has a source that's within the
intelligence community that he claims
brought this information to him he's
viewed he's reviewed it he's taken down
the the document and numbers involved he
wants other members of the committee to
view it but I think in this case he's
very protective of an internal source
within the intelligence community but
that's less important I think than
having real clarity about what's going
on you know what do you think this
information will tell us I think
ultimately that it may tell us that this
was not that big of a deal that this was
a situation where they that they had
incidental collection of information
perhaps conversations between foreign
officials about their own meetings with
the Trump transition team where they
expected certain family members for
instance to end up with in the White
House team but we don't know that until
we actually have this information and
that's one of the reasons we need more
clarity from this committee from
Chairman Nunez sooner rather than later
Ben thank you so much for joining me
with you